je propose donc de commencer notre
audition donc merci
à Madame Sylvie Montout responsable de
projet en charge de l'évaluation du plan
de relance et à Monsieur Vincent aussi
loup directeur du département économie
et finances de France stratégique
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
monsieur aussi doux vous êtes économiste
responsable du département économie et
finances de France stratégie depuis plus
de 8 ans vous exerciez précédemment des
responsabilités au sein de cabinet
ministériel ainsi qu'à la Commission
européenne et au ministère de l'Économie
madame Montou vous êtes vous aussi
économiste et responsable de projet chez
France stratégie en charge de
dévaluation du plan de relance vous
étiez auparavant économiste auprès de
business Ford France précédemment agence
française pour les investissements
internationaux
ma prime rénove par exemple soutient
essentiellement des rénovations dites
rénovation monogestes avec 83% des
dossiers validés en 2021 ce qui
représentait 55% du montant des primes
accordées vous notiez aussi que les
travaux de rénovation financés par les
aides publiques sont marqués par la
prédominance des travaux liés au
chauffage avec ce chiffre marquant de
70% des dossiers ma prime rénov en 2021
comment expliquer vous de tels résultats
dans quelle mesure des dispositions
législatives et réglementaires
pourraient infléchir ces résultats vous
expliquer par ailleurs que l'évaluation
précise des politiques de rénovation
énergétique et parfois difficiles vous
nous expliquerez pourquoi et quels sont
les moyens mobilisables pour améliorer
le suivi et
encore risque d'effet rebonds
c'est-à-dire de changement de
comportement après travaux certains
ménages choisissant par exemple
d'augmenter leur température de
chauffage avant de vous laisser la
parole pour répondre à ses premières
questions pour un propos introductif
d'une vingtaine de minutes à vous
répartir bien évidemment comme vous le
souhaitez il me revient de vous indiquer
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct et en différé sur le site
internet du scénario qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc madame et monsieur a
prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité
et a levé la main droite et à dire je ne
jure
je vous remercie donc je vous laisse
bien sûr la parole pour une vingtaine de
minutes ensuite notre rapporteur vous
posera un certain nombre de questions
ainsi que les membres de la commission
qui sont présentes dans cette salle
c'est à vous
donc déjà en termes d'introduction sur
la question justement des principaux
obstacles à la massification et puis à
la montée en qualité de rénovation
énergétique puisque nous savons que dans
notre pays en France en comparaison
d'autres pays européens nous sommes très
en dessous en termes de performance
justement des de des émissions pour le
pour le bâtiment et en manque de
rénovation énergétique performante c'est
un enjeu absolument essentiel contenu de
ce que représente les bâtiments pour les
émissions carbone et la consommation
d'énergie 27% pour les émissions carbone
près de 45% pour la consommation
d'énergie c'est absolument essentiel
pour notre trajectoire et notre objectif
de zéro émission nette pour 2050 nous
étions jusqu'à récemment en dessous de
la trajectoire sur les deux dernières
années un peu plus proche de la
trajectoire mais nous sommes quand même
très très loin de
ce qu'il faut atteindre en termes de
nombre de rénovation énergétique
performantes
pour le Haut Conseil pour le climat nous
devrions nous devrions être à partir de
2023 sur 370 000 rénovations
énergétiques performantes or en
2021-2022 nous n'avons été qu'à 50 000
et par ailleurs à partir de 2030 il
faudra attendre atteindre 700 000
rénovations énergétiques performantes
donc nous sommes très loin de ces de ces
objectifs là et clairement les nous
avons étudié justement les obstacles la
question absolument centrale c'est le
financement puisque nous mobilisons déjà
beaucoup
d'aide publique et aussi beaucoup
d'argent des ménages pour investir dans
la rénovation énergétique c'est sur les
dernières années 15 milliards d'euros
d'investissement mais selon l'institut
i4ce
pour être sur la trajectoire de
rénovation énergétique globale
performante
donc en accord avec la trajectoire bas
carbone il faudrait 10 milliards d'euros
d'investissement supplémentaires par an
et par ailleurs si on est sur des
rénovations globales en une fois
et là-dessus bien évidemment on sait que
à la fois côté finance publique nous
avons déjà pas mal de contraintes nous
savons aussi bien entendu que les
particuliers ont également beaucoup de
contraintes sur leur financement y
compris les gens qui pourraient
emprunter mais on sait que
faire de l'emprunt s'endetter même pour
ceux qui peuvent le faire c'est souvent
un frein un obstacle il y a et par
ailleurs y compris ceux qui peuvent se
s'endetter lorsqu'ils achètent un
logement souvent sont au maximum du prêt
qu'ils peuvent obtenir et s'ils doivent
faire des travaux complémentaires pour
améliorer le bâtiment le logement qu'il
rachète souvent ils sont en limite de du
prêt qu'il qu'ils peuvent obtenir donc
la question de financement est vraiment
la question essentielle et là-dessus
nous avons travaillé justement sur le
fait d'essayer d'évaluer qu'elle pouvait
être le nouveau vecteur pour aider à
financer en complément donc des aides
publiques et en complément de
l'investissement financé par les
particuliers et de ce point de vue là
nous avons un enjeu collectif qui est de
mieux mobiliser les économies d'énergie
comme source de financement justement de
la rénovation énergétique puisque on
sait que justement ces économies
d'énergie vont dégager du pouvoir
d'achat et qu'elles peuvent être
mobilisées en amont pour financer donc
c'est rénovation énergétique performante
sans que ça soit nécessairement un prêt
donc un emprunt pour les particuliers et
mobiliser ses ressources d'un point de
vue global de la nation ça serait
beaucoup plus efficace malheureusement
aujourd'hui elles sont mal mobilisées et
par ailleurs alors d'autres d'autres
obstacles majeurs c'est notamment la
complexité pour les particuliers
lorsqu'ils souhaitent faire la
rénovation énergétique de leur logement
la multiplicité des acteurs avec
lesquels ils doivent traiter et même
aujourd'hui avec le guichet unique
France rénov même avec les sociétés de
tiers financement qui existent depuis un
moment ça reste quand même assez
complexe pour les particuliers
parce que ils ont des relations avec
différentes entreprises puisque on n'a
pas des entreprises qui font des
opérations globales qui
se responsabilise pour l'ensemble donc
de l'offre près du particulier
et par ailleurs on sait aussi que comme
il y a eu des périodes avec une partie
de rénovation énergétique
très peu performante
qu'il y a un manque de confiance
aujourd'hui dans les acteurs de
l'écosystème il est donc très important
qu'on arrive à reconstruire cette
confiance en arrivant à aligner les
intérêts donc de l'entreprise qui va
réaliser les travaux avec les intérêts
des particuliers et nos intérêts
collectifs qui sont arrivés à faire la
rénovation énergétique la plus
performante au meilleur coût et de ce
point de vue là donc c'est c'est
extrêmement important de pouvoir aligner
ses intérêts
par ailleurs
on sait également qu'il y a un sujet
pour les
propriétés les particuliers qui sont
propriétaires de logement et qu'il est
louent et qui doivent porter
l'investissement sans eux-mêmes
en bénéficier directement justement des
économies d'énergie que cela génère donc
ils doivent porter l'investissement mais
c'est le les bénéfices ce sont les
locataires qui vont en bénéficier au
départ et donc il est il est utile de
trouver une solution qui permette
d'aligner justement aussi ces intérêts
et donc c'est en ce sens que
nous avons travaillé à France stratégie
sur la solution que nous appelons les
opérateurs enseignés ou l'entreprise qui
à la fois fait la conception dans les
travaux fait la maîtrise d'oeuvre donc
pilote les différences sous-traitants et
elle porte l'investissement dans la
rénovation énergétique et elle se
rembourse en complément des aides
publiques donc pour payer le reste à
charge elle se rembourse en fait
via les économies d'énergie sur la
facture énergétique du ménage donc les
propriétaires
et les locataires ne dépensent pas plus
que s'il ne faisait pas la rénovation
énergétique mais il bénéficie donc de la
rénovation énergétique dans le meilleur
confort aussi on sait que ça a des
conséquences en termes de santé
notamment pour les passoires dans les
passeurs thermiques il y a des grands
enjeux en termes de santé et donc là ça
permettrait de mobiliser vraiment les
les économies d'énergie pour financer
sans que les particuliers nés à
s'endetter ni à faire des avances à
mobiliser leur épargne
et donc de ce point de vue là il y a
donc la possibilité de il y a pas mal
d'acteurs qui se sont déclarés
intéressés et donc ça serait important
de pouvoir le lancer rapidement pour
bien évidemment
ça ne sera pas nécessairement la réponse
à tout mais une partie une bonne partie
des rénovations énergétiques peuvent
être financées de cette manière là nous
avons fait les calculs avant la montée
des prix de l'énergie c'était déjà un
logement sur trois qui pouvait être pour
lesquels la rénovation énergétique
performante pouvait être financée par
les économies d'énergie maintenant avec
des prix d'énergie plus élevées c'est
une une partie plus importante et par
ailleurs on pourrait également optimiser
les aides publiques pour justement les
mieux les mobiliser pour les
les bâtiments sur lesquels il n'y a pas
à la rentabilité de la rénovation
énergétique via les économies sur la
facture d'énergie
et bien évidemment en tenant compte
aussi des revenus des propriétaires
et ça on sait que c'est souvent des
bâtiments historiques pour lesquels les
donc par exemple les immeubles
haussmanniens ou quoi que ce soit pour
lesquels et les bâtiments qui sont
souvent en centre-ville pour lesquels
les
l'investissement de rénovation et plus
et plus cher et donc là les aides
publiques pour être optimales optimisés
pour mieux aider à rénover ce type de
bâtiment alors que d'autres bâtiments
auraient moins besoin d'aide d'être
public donc là dessus enfin en résumé le
vraiment la question du financement la
question de la simplification pour les
particuliers donc là d'avoir une
relation avec un opérateur ensemble une
seule entreprise qui est en contact avec
le particulier qui s'engage à porter
l'investissement pour la rénovation
énergétique à réaliser les travaux et
donc piloter les travaux réalisés par
d'autres sous-traitants et c'est elle
qui les paye directement et ensuite
c'est un partage sur les économies
d'énergie qui finance l'investissement
porté par cette entreprise que nous
appelons opérateur en sanglier par
ailleurs du coup ça permet d'aligner
l'intérêt des
des propriétaires avec les locataires
dans les copropriétés et bien entendu ça
a une garantie en termes d'efficacité et
de performance puisque l'opérateur en
sanglier se rembourse sur les économies
d'énergie donc si il réalise mal les
travaux ou s'il a aussi les travaux sont
plus chers que ce qu'il avait anticipé
c'est lui qui porte les les la pertes en
fait
la dégradation de sa rentabilité
éventuellement les particuliers
là-dessus n'ont pas du coup de risque
c'est beaucoup plus simple à gérer ça ça
aligne donc leurs intérêts avec
l'entreprise qui fait la rénovation
énergétique
par ailleurs donc
clairement il y aura des
des intérêts aussi dans ce dispositif là
à ce que
du coup des collectivités territoriales
fassent des choix de ces opérateurs
ensemble billets pour gérer des
quartiers des territoires parce qu'on
sait que il y a une possibilité
d'optimiser les la rénovation
énergétique de faire baisser les coûts
unitaires si on réalise l'animation
énergétique sur l'ensemble d'un quartier
alors bien évidemment
lorsque la collectivité territoriale
choisie un opérateur ensemble lié ça ne
veut pas dire que chacun des des
propriétaires sur le quartier est obligé
de passer par cette opérateur sanglier
mais clairement ils auront quand même
une incitation parce que les coûts
seront moins chers parce qu'il y aura
plus de confiance aussi parce que quand
même c'est à dire quand même sur la
confiance du choix par la commune et par
ailleurs donc en termes d'efficacité on
sait que ça sera nettement plus efficace
y compris en équipant les bâtiments par
la possibilité de produire de l'énergie
donc favoriser l'autoconsommation c'est
que c'est un enjeu absolument essentiel
y compris aussi bien entendu
développer la géothermie de surface
et d'ailleurs au-delà de du question de
la question de la gestion des
rénovations énergétiques ce type de
d'opérateur pourrait aussi prendre en
charge la question de la rénovation de
la gestion de l'eau puisque nous savons
que nous avons un enjeu absolument
essentiel de ce point de vue là et que
comme les rénovations énergétiques font
amène quand même un des travaux
importants lorsqu'on veut atteindre une
performance globale performante
c'est clairement aussi quelque chose qui
peut être géré en parallèle et financer
là pour le coup par les économies sur la
facture d'eau
et on sait qu'on a un enjeu absolument
essentiel dans notre pays de plus en
plus de ce point de vue là
alors peut-être
je peux laisser la parole à Sylvie
manteau pour donner quelques résultats
un peu plus en détail sur justement dans
le cadre de l'évaluation que nous avons
menée dans le dans le pour le comité
d'évaluation du plan de relance
présenter quelques résultats plus en
détail sur justement ma prime rénove que
nous avons
étudié en détail et qui montre
effectivement le constat que nous devons
arriver à progresser sur les rénovations
globales performantes et pas juste du
mot du monogest
merci Vincent
madame la Présidente vous avez déjà mis
en évidence les principales conclusions
néanmoins je j'essaierai dans cette
présentation brève d'aller à l'essentiel
sur peut-être au-delà des limites qui
ont déjà été présentées par Monsieur
aussiou de voir aussi en termes
déficience les résultats positifs mais
également les alertes que nous faisons
notamment en termes de rénovation
globale
il donc je vais pas vous faire la
gageure de vous présenter ma prime
rénove mais néanmoins de souligner qu'il
y a eu déjà des évolutions qui sont en
cours depuis la fin 2022 avec notamment
la mise en place de la plateforme France
rénove mon accompagnateur est noble qui
sont des éléments essentiels puisque
lors de la première évaluation
effectivement en octobre 2021 nous
avions mis en évidence très rapidement
qu'il y avait un manque d'accompagnement
au niveau des ménages et que et que ce
manque d'accompagnement avait pour
conséquence directe une
véritable massification des travaux mais
surtout des démonogestes
donc les principaux bénéficiaires
restent bien les ménages modestes et si
on regarde un des éléments importants
qui est le reste à charge on voit en
fait que ce reste à charge reste
important pour les ménages très modestes
puisque lorsqu'on cumule l'ensemble des
aides alors encore une fois c'est une
estimation qui n'est pas exhaustive
puisque nous n'avons pas accès à toutes
les aides dont peuvent bénéficier les
ménages et on a ici qu'à partir des
données individuelles de ma prime rénov
à partir de qui nous ont été fournis par
l'opérateur Lana les déclarations des
ménages donc ça n'est qu'une première
estimation donc cette cette part peut
être plus faible néanmoins elle reste
importante et c'est la raison pour
laquelle en mars 2022 il y a eu un
décret qui a mis en oeuvre donc le
nouveau écho prêt à tout 0 qui a été mis
en place à la fin de l'année 2022 donc
nous espérons que lors de la nouvelle
évaluation on sera en mesure de voir ses
effets
donc sur les monogestes vous en avez
parlé on reste à des niveaux très
importants et ce que l'on observe en
termes de gestes c'est que la plupart
des gestes qui sont sollicités par les
ménages sont les travaux liés au
chauffage et à la ventilation
donc c'est gains sont néanmoins pas
négligeables puisque lorsqu'on regarde
le gain théorique il est égal il est
supérieur en termes de lorsqu'on prend
le gain par logement il est supérieur de
40% au dispositif antérieur à ma prime
rénove qui était le Crédit Impôt
transition énergétique
un des une des limites importantes c'est
qu'effectivement lorsqu'on regarde
également la corrélation entre le taux
de subvention et le gain énergétique
par eurotravault on voit que finalement
ce sont ce ne sont pas les travaux qui
sont les plus efficients en termes de
gains énergétique qui sont les mieux
subventionnés donc il y a c'est
notamment le cas pour les pompes à
chaleur air eau et la chaudière gaz THPE
et donc
alors que lorsqu'on regarde l'isolation
des murs par
l'extérieur notamment par l'intérieur
notamment on a
des résultats en termes de performance
qui sont importantes et le taux de
subvention qui reste fait donc là on
voit déjà ne serait-ce que par ce cette
corrélation qu'il y a déjà gestes que
l'on pourrait remettre en cause en terme
de subventions puisque en termes de de
gain de réduction de consommation
énergétique
le gain n'est pas suffisant par rapport
au taux subventionné néanmoins un des
points qui est important et qui est
des résultats les plus importants pour
ma prime rénov c'est que
on a un impact important sur la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre et
cela est dû notamment
au gestes que nous avons mentionnés que
sont le poil à granulés la pompe à
chaleur air eau et donc c'est ces
travaux même s'ils restent prédominants
en termes de monogestes ces travaux
néanmoins en un impact important et
significatif sur les réductions de gaz à
effet de serre et donc si pour le coup
on n'est pas en
adéquation avec les objectifs de la
Stratégie nationale bas carbone en
termes de rénovation performante on les
en termes de réduction des gaz à effet
de serre donc c'est quand même un point
important qu'il faut qu'il faut noter
nous avions également regardé mais
peut-être pas ma pesantir sur le fait de
vérifier que ma prime rénove était
également sollicitée par des territoires
des départements qui avaient des
caractéristiques en termes de précarité
énergétique
importante et donc en tout cas qui avait
un besoin en termes de rénovation et ce
qu'on observe
c'est à peu près le cas à l'exception
des de l'Île-de-France où là où on voit
il y a un taux de précarité un taux de
passoire en tout cas thermique qui est
importante alors que le recours à ma
prime rénove est faible et cela
s'explique par des éléments qui a
mentionné monsieur aussi you c'est non
seulement le fait que pour les
copropriétés les propriétaires bailleurs
on peut ont eu peu recours à ma prime
rénove copropriété et le deuxième écueil
c'est qu'effectivement il y a une
difficulté
dans le collectif pour mettre en place
les procédures mais il y a aussi la
difficulté pour les villes comme Paris
du fait qu'on est des bâtiments
historiques et il y a des conditions et
des réglementations strictes à respecter
alors un des points
qui nous paraît très important c'est
justement sur les rénovations globales
sur les rénovation globale en regardant
ma prime rénove sérénité qui est le
dispositif qui se substitue à habiter
mieux sérénité on a environ on a estimé
environ 60 000 rénovations
dites globale
pour l'année
2021 mais ce qu'on observe ici dans ces
différents graphiques c'est le fait que
même quand il y a des rénovations qui
vont induire un gain énergétique très
important
c'est
ces gars ne sont pas suffisants pour
permettre
des sorties de passoire thermique et
donc c'est ce que vous voyez lorsqu'on
regarde par exemple pour les les
étiquettes de FAF ou de de Gad et de où
là on a des gains qui sont parmi les
gains les plus importants énergétiques
moyennes les plus importants mais
pourtant
c'est c'est logement restent des
passoires thermiques et donc il y a
toute la question effectivement derrière
identifier les bons gestes puisque là il
y a un audit néanmoins donc il y a bien
un audit avec avec un
accenté donc un audit avant travaux qui
permet justement de d'estimer le gain
attendu donc le gain attendu et
significatif il ne permet néanmoins pas
les sorties de passoire thermique
puisque l'ensemble de ces rénovations
globales ont permis 57% de sortie de
passoire thermique
donc
en conclusion il y a plusieurs il y a
plusieurs éléments mais
parmi les principaux donc il y a bien
sûr une massification des travaux de
rénovation
qui est qui en tout cas un résultat qui
était attendu et qui a été atteint
les économies en termes de CO2 sont
importantes et sont et sont
effectivement
en adéquation avec les objectifs de la
CNBC en revanche la grosse limite de ce
dispositif mais peut-être que ce n'est
pas non plus son ambition première
était de déclencher des aides déclencher
des rénovations d'ampleur et donc ces
rénovations d'ampleur qu'on appelle
[Musique]
le terme le plus le plus le plus récent
qui est celui des rénovations
performantes et globale et donc en fait
qui sont des rénovations qui doivent des
gestes en tout cas qui doivent être
réalisés dans un temps déterminé donc
pas plus de 18 mois avec qui serait
équipé avec une la vérification de la
cohérence de la simultana simultanéité
de certains gestes avec bien sûr
l'objectif d'un gain énergétique qui
soit significatif
[Musique]
donc ici la grosse difficulté aussi et
de et de
massifier ces travaux de rénovation dans
les logements collectifs dans les
copropriétés puisque ces logements
représentent plus de la moitié des
résidences principales or là ma prime
rénove concerne essentiellement des
maisons individuelles donc là il y a une
véritable un véritable enjeu donc nous
les premiers chiffres que nous avions
les premières données auxquelles nous
allions pu accéder nous avons environ eu
un accès très faible effectivement des
ménages à ma prime rénov copropriété il
semblerait que pour l'année 2022 on est
une progression mais je pense qu'on
reste néanmoins très en dessous des
attentes et là la grosse difficulté
c'est la c'est l'horizon de temps
puisque pour que la copropriété puisse
engager des travaux il faut qu'il y ait
une assemblée générale donc il faut que
les copropriétaires se
réunissent il faut donc en général c'est
une fois par an et puis après il faut
bien sûr la majorité
pour que les travaux puissent être
enclenchés donc en fait à ce stade le
processus est difficile et peut
expliquer le faible recours
outre le fait qu'effectivement on a
aussi des contraintes très forts dans
les dans les grandes
dans les grandes métropoles
vous aviez également
parler de la du fait que jusqu'à présent
l'ensemble des travaux
sont basés sur des estimations
théoriques notamment basées sur
l'enquête Rémy du commissariat général
développement durable et donc nous en
avons conscience et donc effectivement
nous avions dans un premier temps
essayer de d'avoir une première
évaluation qui était réalisée avec avec
une entreprise aumée pour vérifier sur
un échantillon qu'elle était à l'impact
des travaux de rénovation bon les
travaux n'ont enfin le nombre de de
répondons n'ayant pas été suffisant nous
n'avons pas pu estimer néanmoins le
service statistique du commissariat
général au développement durable à
prévu cette année d'accéder pour un
million de ménages alors l'ensemble des
ménages qui vont réaliser des travaux de
rénovation énergétique donc pas
seulement ma prime rénov mais l'ensemble
des travaux d'accéder justement à la
consommation
des ménages leur permettant donc nous
espérons soit d'ici la fin 2023 ou 2024
d'être en capacité d'estimer l'impact
des travaux de rénovation qui prendra en
compte la consommation réelle et les
faire bon
donc là c'est peut-être pour ma prime
rénov la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments privés juste un mot pour dire
que sur les bâtiments publics qui me
semble que c'est aussi un enjeu
important alors je sais pas si votre
vous abordez ou pas à ce sujet parce
qu'il y a enfin dans pour les bâtiments
publics qui a quand même également un
nombre de
bâtiments qui sont de vrais passoires
thermiques et donc il y a un enjeu en
terme de de consommation énergétique un
enjeu environnemental mais également
sociétal
merci beaucoup alors c'est vrai qu'on
est plus donc spécifiquement accès sur
le logement mais on a eu des auditions
sur lesquelles effectivement le sujet
aussi des bâtiments publics et a été
évoqué je laisse la parole à notre
rapporteur
merci madame le Président merci pour
votre
de présentation
moi j'avais déjà une première question
par rapport peut-être par rapport à ce
que vous avez dit sur le sur ce qu'il
faudrait en termes de financement
puisque vous disiez qu'il y avait 15
milliards d'investissements qui étaient
déjà engagés et qui en faudrait quasi 10
milliards de 10 milliards de plus
c'est vrai que souvent les différents
ministres qu'on a pu interroger on a eu
des chiffres assez assez différents mais
par rapport en fait à ces montants j'ai
reçu on imaginé qu'on avait ces 10
milliards est-ce que vous pensez que du
coup on pourrait réellement réaliser ces
travaux quoi puisque après il faut avoir
l'argent encore faut-il l'utiliser il
faut que les entreprises soient en
capacité de pouvoir le faire donc déjà
sur cette sur cette sur ce premier
aspect et puis ensuite sur ce que vous
ce que vous présentiez avec ce système
là avec un opérateur en sanglier donc de
faire converger on va dire les intérêts
que je trouve assez assez intéressant
et donc du coup de se rembourser on va
dire de se payer sur les économies des
économies d'énergie donc ça paraît assez
vertueux mais c'est vrai que j'avais
plusieurs questions à la fois vous avez
un peu évoqué mais sur la question de
l'augmentation du coût de l'énergie
parce que c'est vrai que autant quand on
était sur une un coup de l'énergie qui
était relativement stable c'était assez
lisible et on pouvait se dire que voilà
je vais faire tant d'économie et donc
sauf que l'on s'aperçoit que
même avec une rénovation on va avoir un
coût énergétique qui va être quasi même
supérieur parfois avant d'avoir fait la
rénovation juste parce que le coût de
l'énergie a doublé et que voilà donc
savoir du coup dans votre dispositif
comment comment intégrer ce coût de
l'énergie et puis dans dans aussi ce que
vous avez ce que vous avez abordé enfin
en tout cas ce qui ce qu'on peut voir
dans la dans votre note sur les
changements de comportement après les
travaux c'est-à-dire le fait que
certains ménages choisissent d'augmenter
par exemple en température de chauffage
l'effet rebond quoi de de
à partir du moment on a un logement qui
est plus plus confortable justement
qu'on a fait baisser le coût énergétique
ben du coup on va vouloir aussi plus de
confort du coup on va chauffer plus et
en fait on va limiter en fait le vrai le
vrai impact du énergétique donc du coup
comment dans ce que vous décrivez vous
pouvez vous arriver en tout cas à
intégrer ça et puis dans le même sens
aussi mais peut-être que j'ai pas
totalement compris j'avais compris qu'en
fait plus on allait plus on investissait
beaucoup et plus on allait sur des
investissements lourds sur de la
rénovation thermique du coup performante
moi en tout cas c'était rentable c'est à
dire que que moi on récupérait
sur sur justement les économies
d'énergie donc du coup c'était aussi un
autre élément parce que du coup ça va
pas dans le sens du coup de ce que vous
décriviez parce que ça veut dire que ça
va rajouter des temps en fait de
remboursement
donc c'était déjà sur ce sur ce
dispositif ce dispositif là
je voulais peut-être avoir aussi votre
avis puisque ça a été eu des discussions
qu'on a pu avoir avec les différents
ministres qu'on a pu additionner sur
justement les différents moyens qu'on
peut avoir pour intervenir à la fois
soit donc là c'est ce qui a été décidé
au niveau législatif d'interdire les
locations de passoire thermique mais il
y avait des discussions aussi qui ont
été qui ont été évoquées sur le fait
d'agir sur des bâtiments soit vente et
donc du coup lors de la vente du coup
avoir cette obligation d'investir lors
de lors de la vente et donc avoir votre
votre avis là-dessus et puis ça me
permet parce que je sais qu'il y a une
proposition de loi citoyenne qui a été
qui a été travaillé je sais pas si vous
en avez eu connaissance mais en fait qui
est un dispositif pour faire court qui
dit que pour avoir reste à ça zéro c'est
à dire qu'en gros chacun puisse investir
ça voudrait dire qu'il y aurait un
illustrer un fond justement de
rénovation qui ressemble un petit peu à
ce que vous dites sauf que au lieu de se
payer justement sur ces économies
d'énergie c'est en fait via une
hypothèque c'est à dire que un bâtiment
en fait le montant est hypothéqué et
c'est justement à la vente que ça vient
ça vient alimenter ce fond
donc voilà je sais pas si vous en avez
eu vous en avez eu connaissance mais
c'était je trouve un système qui se
rapproche un petit peu de ce que vous
avez pu de ce que vous avez pu décrire
voilà ce que j'avais comme question et
puis peut-être sur la question des la
fiabilité des DPE aussi puisque c'est
vrai que pareil dans ce que vous avez
décrit on voit bien qu'on a la nécessité
d'avoir des despe qui soit qui soit
fiables donc on a déjà vu l'évolution
donc savoir ce que à la fois vous pensez
par rapport aux nouveaux DPE et du coup
leur place justement dans ces
différentes dans ces différentes
politiques et puis une dernière question
sur les matériaux biosourcés
sur le fait que
le chiffre est pas peut-être pas
forcément exact mais on estime qu'il y a
à peu près 90% des matériaux utilisés
dans la rénovation thermique qui sont
plutôt liées avec des
des matériaux liés
l'industrie pétrochimique et donc sur
l'évolution et le faire en sorte de
plutôt se tourner vers des matériaux
biosourcés et du coup sur la mise en
place la mise en place de filières
et qui sont aussi quelque chose qui
pourrait rentrer en terme de financement
puisqu'on voit aussi qu'on a un lien
notamment sur le stockage carbone
si on prend l'exemple du champ avec du
stockage de carbone qui ensuite se
retrouve dans le bâtiment et donc qui
est un vrai stockage sur du sur du long
terme quoi et donc sur le fait qu'on
peut donner du coup une valeur à ce à ce
carbone qui est qui est stockée
voilà merci
oui quelques réponses donc à vos
questions alors sur le déjà sur la part
de l'investissement donc sur les 15
milliards d'euros d'investissement qui
sont réalisés dans le pays dans la
rénovation énergétique pour les pour les
logements privés
c'est donc
clairement il y a un enjeu parce que
c'est cette somme n'est pas mobilisée de
manière performante pour les rénovations
énergétiques
l'Institut 4 ces estime que sur ces 15
milliards d'euros c'est 8 milliards
d'euros qui ne génèrent pas des
économies d'énergie
donc il y a et sachant que sur ces 15
milliards d'euros sur les sur les
dernières années c'était près de 6
milliards d'euros d'aides publiques
donc clairement nous avons un enjeu de
mieux mobiliser ces investissements pour
des rénovations énergétiques
performantes et donc c'est
le 8 milliards qui génèrent pas
d'économies d'énergie c'est quoi par
exemple alors c'est des gestes de
rénovation qui soit sont justement pas
performants soit trop soit fait
justement de manière trop
indépendante et on sait que dans ce cas
là une bonne partie d'entre eux ne
génère pas de d'économie d'énergie quoi
et comme
dans le cas classique
une entreprise n'a pas un intérêt à
lignée avec les particuliers que quand
elle réalise les travaux que ça génère
vraiment des économies d'énergie on sait
qu'on a eu dans certains cas de figures
alors bien entendu pas par la majorité
des entreprises mais une partie d'entre
elles qui du coup en dégradé la
confiance des particuliers dans
l'écosystème parce que certaines
réaliser des rénovations du plafond par
exemple ou quoi que ce soit qui qui ne
donnaient pas d'efficacité pas
d'économie d'énergie quoi
et
du coup ça ça pose beaucoup de problèmes
pour les pour les particuliers
et alors de ce point de vue là
alors sur les questions pour la mise en
oeuvre du de l'opérateur ensemble lié
sur le coup de l'énergie justement ça ce
n'est pas un sujet ce n'est pas un
problème puisque en réalité le la
logique c'est de calculer l'écart de la
facture qui aurait eu lieu s'il n'y
avait pas eu la rénovation énergétique
et avec l'écart de la facture
énergétique post-rénovation et c'est 7
et 4 entre les deux qui est partagé
entre les particuliers et l'opérateur en
sanglier et pour l'opérateur sambier
pour financer l'investissement donc ça
ne veut pas dire que la facture
énergétique déménage n'augmentera jamais
si jamais les prix d'énergie augmentée
fortement même donc
même après la rénovation énergétique ça
peut elle peut augmenter mais elle
augmenterait beaucoup moins que il
n'avait pas eu la rénovation énergétique
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il est
important de mobiliser ces économies
d'énergie pour la financer pour la
réaliser et par ailleurs si
en revanche les prix de l'énergie baisse
fortement alors ce qui est peu probable
pour les énergies renouvelables mais qui
n'est pas totalement
exclu notamment pour les énergies
carbonées parce que si on est rentré en
récession mondiale
il pourrait y avoir de ce point de vue
là un effondrement du prix du gaz par
exemple
et là de ce point de vue là pour un
opérateur en sanglier qui aurait porté
l'investissement une des clauses dans le
contrat c'est que la durée du contrat
peut être
prolongée un peu automatiquement si
jamais les retours sur investissement
est plus faible du fait de d'une baisse
des coûts d'énergie et donc de ce point
de vue là c'est à la fois toujours
intéressant pour les particuliers et ça
limite les risques pour les opérateurs
en sangliers
et par ailleurs ça serait intéressant
que la puissance publique mobilise un
fond de garantie qui alors ne couvrirait
pas l'ensemble des pertes mais pourrait
en prendre une partie par exemple
lorsqu'on opérateur en sanglier c'est
une perte le fond de garantie pourrait
en couvrir 50%. donc on est sûr qu'en en
couvrant 50% l'opérateur semble dit
garde quand même l'intérêt aligné avec
ne pas réaliser de pertes donc ne pas
mal maîtriser les travaux ne pas mal
anticiper énergie qui sont réalisés etc
les intérêts se resteraient toujours
alignés mais ça permettrait donc de à la
puissance publique d'avoir de mieux
mobiliser les fonds pour que les aides
soient plus efficaces justement en
développant beaucoup plus les
investissements par les acteurs privés
pour dans le donc les investissements
par des entreprises dans la dans la
transition énergétique des bâtiments et
ceci à la place des investissements fait
directement par les particuliers et sur
les sur le la question relative à
l'évolution de la consommation d'énergie
post-rénovation là il y a plusieurs
moyens plusieurs techniques pour pouvoir
le contrôler faire le partage de ce qui
est dû à la rénovation énergétique
ce qui est le partage de ce qui est dû
au changement de comportement du ménage
qui habite dans le logement
il y a différentes techniques possibles
une technique c'est notamment et c'est
là où c'est important de développer en
fait des diagnostics thermiques
performants donc il y a des initiatives
là qui se développent notamment le
diagnostic sereine pour renforcer en
fait le diagnostic de profonde de
performance énergétique qui pourrait
être fait par un acteur tiers donc pas
l'opérateur ensemble lié mais par un
autre qui ferait le diagnostic de
performance énergétique avant rénovation
et un autre poste rénovation qui permet
de déterminer un comportement échangé
quelle est la part de baisse de la
consommation énergétique
ça c'est par exemple d'attributs de dire
de sur la base de ce diagnostic
performant
que la comportement a changé la
consommation énergétique du bâtiment
baisse de 50% du coup le calcul de la
facture qui aurait eu lieu s'il n'avait
pas eu la rénovation énergétique c'est
juste
facile en appliquant donc en doublant
par rapport à la facture qui a lieu
poste rénovation donc si le nombre de
personnes qui habitent dans le logement
augmente si le ménage par exemple a
aussi bien entendu passer de véhicules
thermiques aux véhicules électriques et
que donc c'est calculé sur sa
consommation d'électricité bien
évidemment ça fait monter sa
consommation mais
cette partie là du coup va bien entendu
sur sa facture quoi la part de
d'économie d'énergie qui est liée à la
rénovation énergétique de ce point là va
à l'opérateur ensemble il y a d'autres
techniques possibles il y a par exemple
une entreprise qui a développé un
système de capteurs l'entreprise obèse
un capteur simple très peu coûteux
qui permet de donc avec un capteur à
l'intérieur du bâtiment un capteur à
l'extérieur de faire justement la part
entre ce qui est un comportement
dispendieux d'utilisation du chauffage
en faisant monter la température en
laissant ouvert les fenêtres
donc son système est très simple et très
peu coûteux et donc ça c'est ça peut
être un choix pour les opérateurs
ensemble et de prendre cette technologie
là pour faire la part des de ce qui est
dû à la
donc les économies d'énergie liées à la
rénovation énergétique et ce qui est dû
aux évolutions de du comportement du
ménage à l'intérieur du bâtiment une
autre possibilité c'est il existe des
systèmes de
compteurs intelligents qui se combinent
avec le compteur Linky pour faire qui
permettent de voir quels sont en termes
de consommation donc d'électricité quand
le chauffage et le reste est
l'électricité de faire la part des
choses entre les différents équipements
euh qui euh
donc pour pour faire la part des choses
entre Ben le ménage a acheté de nouveaux
équipements de nouveaux véhicules
électriques par exemple etc donc ça
c'est bien entendu ça se reporte sur sa
facture parce que ça indépendamment de
la rénovation énergétique de toute façon
ça serait reporté sur sa facture
donc ça c'est plusieurs c'est plusieurs
façons de faire et justement un des
avantages de la solution de l'opérateur
ensemblier c'est que comme
dans un premier temps les gains sur la
facture énergétique ne reviennent pas
directement au ménage mais en priorité
revienne à l'opérateur en sanglier pour
payer les travaux l'investissement des
travaux du coup
ça entraîne moins d'effets rebonds
contrairement à une situation où bien
évidemment quand on le constate
aujourd'hui quand la baisse de la
facture énergétique est importante
souvent le réflexe c'est d'en consommer
plus quoi
et donc là justement ne la faisant pas
baisser beaucoup ça n'incite pas à
consommer plus et par ailleurs un autre
intérêt aussi c'est que bien évidemment
l'opérateur incendié qui reste en
contrat avec les particuliers sur une
longue période tant que du coup les le
les investissements ne sont pas
remboursés par les économies d'énergie
il peut
s'il voit des comportements
mal adaptés en termes de consommation
énergétique il peut juste se rapprocher
des particuliers en leur disant
attention vous avez là vous avez des
pratiques qui font qui font dépenser
beaucoup plus on peut on peut vous aider
vous conseiller bien évidemment ça reste
du choix des particuliers de d'adapter
ou pas leur comportement voir
éventuellement aussi de les accompagner
dans le choix d'équipements par exemple
d'avoir de la domotique qui permet de
mieux piloter les équipements et pas
simplement les équipements de chauffage
ou d'eau chaude
mais de les autres équipements de
consommation électrique qu'il consomme
par exemple
à des moments où on n'est pas dans les
pointes électriques etc donc ça c'est de
ce point de vue là c'est aussi un des
avantages de la solution c'est que ça
permet de mieux contrôler l'effet
rebonds et de et aussi contrairement à
la situation actuelle où une entreprise
fait une rénovation énergétique une fois
qu'elle a fait les travaux qu'on lui a
payé sa facture rapidement elle est plus
elle est plus partie prenante et donc
d'ailleurs si du coup ça n'est pas
performant
pour elle c'est terminé et puis si les
comportements ne sont pas adaptés c'est
pas elle qui va faire un suivi et aider
les ménages à mieux adapter leur
comportement pour faire baisser leur
consommation quoi
par ailleurs donc
sur ce point il y a des expérimentations
de ce système là où à l'étranger je sais
pas mais enfin qui alors c'est un
système qui pour l'instant n'a pas été
mis en place et pas à l'étranger
justement alors on a justement un France
stratégie étudié des situations qui sont
assez proches mais qui ne qui justement
n'avait pas exactement ces
caractéristiques et ces deux cette
manière là qu'on a établi justement
les les caractéristiques de l'opérateur
en sanglier pour répondre aux problèmes
qui avaient
généré donc du coup
des difficultés dans la mise en oeuvre
de concepts un peu similaires notamment
les sociétés de tiers financement sont
très proches de ce dispositif mais la
différence c'est que les sociétés de
tiers financement mobilisent des prêts
par ailleurs ne sont pas responsabilisés
complètement sur le
sur la performance puisqu'elle se
rembourse pas sur les sur la performance
post rénovation et donc justement
plusieurs des sociétés de tiers
financement sont intéressés à passer à
la société de tiers investissement de
porter l'investissement et du coup de
rembourser le l'investissement réalisé
par les économies d'énergie quoi
bien évidemment elle les sociétés
financement dès maintenant
essaye de faire en sorte que la facture
au ménage donc le financement de son
prêt ne soit pas supérieur à l'économie
qu'il va faire sur sa facture d'énergie
mais ça n'est pas quelque chose de
vraiment intégré et par ailleurs on sait
que même avec les sociétés de tiers
financement malheureusement ou les pour
les ménages le choix des le choix des
artisans leur relation etc est assez
compliqué un autre problème par exemple
aussi qu'on a bien vu notamment en
parlant avec des ménages qui qui ont été
face à des problèmes c'est que la
mobilisation des des aides lorsqu'on
veut faire une rénovation énergétique
performante donc avec plusieurs gestes
etc c'est souvent très compliqué à
mobiliser et ils ont ils leur manque
enfin ils passent souvent beaucoup de
temps avant d'être sûr qu'il s pourront
avoir des aides avec en plus
l'obligation de d'artisans RGE par
exemple etc qui et donc certains nous
ont dit il nous a fallu plus de six mois
pour savoir si on allait avoir des aides
or nous on venait d'acheter un bâti on
venait d'acheter une maison on devait
faire des travaux de rénovation on
voulait faire des travaux de rénovation
énergétique en même temps mais on
n'était pas sûr de d'obtenir les aides
donc du coup on a fait nos travaux de
rénovation sans faire la rénovation
énergétique
et
bon c'est là clairement comme comme vous
le l'indiquez c'est très important
justement au moment des ventes
demandent donc des opérations d'avoir
justement cette proposition de pouvoir
faire ce financement par les économies
d'énergie alors la suggestion
effectivement de d'avoir une obligation
au moment des ventes de la rénovation
énergétique ça serait quelque chose de
très important notamment pour plus pour
les bien entendu pour les maisons
individuelles puisqu'on sait que dans
les copropriétés c'est un appartement
qui se vend et qu'on peut pas faire la
rénovation d'un juste d'un appartement
individuellement des de l'ensemble du
bâtiment ça ne serait pas performant en
revanche dans la maison individuelle là
il pourrait y avoir éventuellement une
obligation pour toutes maisons qui a un
DPE faible de
d'avoir l'obligation de rénovation
énergétique au moment de la vente et que
ça soit intégré du coup ça serait une
forte bien entendu pour les pour les
propriétaires de l'intégrer dans leur
prix de vente ou bien de le faire
justement avant la vente via un système
d'opérateurs enseigné puisqu'en plus le
contrat d'opérateurs ensemble liés du
propriétaire peut se transmettre au
prochain propriétaire qui continue donc
à payer via la facture énergétique le
remboursement de l'investissement parce
que ça sont l'achat du prix de la maison
aurait été moins cher pour pour lui
et par ailleurs donc effectivement le
fond que vous suggérer enfin cliquez sur
les hypothèques à la vente alors il y a
un système de prêt déjà de remboursement
mais
concrètement il est peu distribué
aujourd'hui peu mobiliser et c'est alors
on n'a pas nécessairement une
explication très claire pourquoi il
n'est pas aussi
mobilisé que que l'intérêt qu'il
présente mais
mon sentiment c'est quand même que les
particuliers enfin ce qu'on a déjà dans
les enquêtes c'est que les particuliers
sont assez réticents à prendre des prêts
et donc c'est peut-être parce que ça a
un aspect prêt et notamment les parents
qui font les travaux et puis qui
anticipent la transmission de leur
logement à leurs enfants
ne veulent pas nécessairement que ça
soit au moment de la transmission que ça
se que ça se rembourse quoi
et par ailleurs
[Musique]
donc il y a on sait que il y a un enjeu
aujourd'hui de que les les banques qui
certes expriment un fort intérêt dans la
dans la volonté de financer les
rénovation énergétiques mais en réalité
il y a quand même très peu de prêts qui
se font et même la distribution du prêt
à taux zéro est très faible par rapport
au potentiel
c'est
en évidence parce que
dans les dans les échanges qu'on a eu
avec l'institutions bancaires ils n'ont
pas elles n'ont pas d'actifs à mettre en
place en face contrairement à la
construction par exemple d'une maison
d'un bâtiments par ailleurs quand elles
font donc quand c'est un prêt pour la
rénovation énergétique par ailleurs
c'est complexe de d'analyser la
situation financière et particuliers de
les risques qui peut y avoir et donc de
ce point de vue là il serait
probablement plus simple que les
institutions financières financent
justement les
qui porte l'investissement
et qui se rembourse sur les économies
d'énergie ça serait pour les banques
plus facile de d'évaluer la situation
financière de l'opérateur ensemble liée
d'évaluer sa performance en termes de
réalisation des
rénovations énergétiques puisque il y
aurait plusieurs opérations qui seraient
réalisées alors que quand c'est un prêt
à un particulier pour une rénovation
énergétique on sait que il en fait pas
plusieurs
d'affilée et donc il est chaque fois un
peu compliqué d'évaluer les risques pour
pour le particulier pour la réalisation
de la de la rénovation énergétique
alors il y en avait une question de
Martin
merci madame la Présidente merci pour
ces explications là moi je voudrais
continuer un petit peu sur les questions
qui ont été posées par notre rapporteur
et notamment sur ce que vous avez défini
comme l'opérateur en sanglier en fait en
tant que tel donc j'ai cru comprendre
donc le mécanisme que vous venez juste à
l'instant de développer
toutefois j'ai vous avez dit d'autres
choses très intéressantes dans votre
présentation notamment madame Montou
puisque on voit que ma prime rénove pour
l'essentiel bénéficie au ménage modestes
83%, voilà il me semble c'est le chiffre
que vous avez annoncé et vous avez
annoncé enfin vous vous avez partagé
autre chose également que nous
connaissons à savoir que parfois malgré
les investissements donc que l'on fait
on ne sort pas du statut de passoire
énergétique donc une fois qu'on a mis
tout ça une fois qu'on ne vous a entendu
monsieur aussi ou sur le mécanisme en
réalité du calcul etc sur le volet en
fait évidemment essentiellement
énergétique je me posais la question
quid de ces situations là comment cela
va se passer concrètement sur ces cas de
figures où vous allez être donc à un
moment donné confronté à des ménage
modestes qui vont prendre après un prêt
malgré bon tout ce que vous avez dit
autour de cela qui vont donc faire des
travaux ces travaux ne vont pas leur
permettre d'arriver enfin de sortir du
statut passoire énergétique si ce n'est
que si j'ai bien compris dans la manière
dont se financerait cet opérateur en
sanglier ben lui il sera quand même pas
mauvais en fait puisque il y aura eu un
progrès énergétique clair vous l'avez
dit vous-même dans vos propos donc ça
c'était ma première question si vous
pouviez quand même nous donner un peu
plus de précision là-dessus et aussi
je me posais également la question en
réalité on c'est vrai que vous êtes au
niveau des économies finances de France
stratégie mais malgré tout un bâtiment
au moment de sa conception
certaines façons au moment de sa fin de
vie on voit qu'aujourd'hui des lois ce
sont déjà notamment je pense à la loi à
Jacques avec les diagnostics etc qu'on
demande et en réalité nous nous
interrogeons aujourd'hui sur la durée de
vie du bâtiment et ce qui peut devenir
en termes d'amélioration
vous vous êtes dans une approche
essentiellement économique évidemment et
donc énergétique mais est-ce que cette
opérateur ensemblier à un moment donné
va avoir un autre apport si je puis dire
vis-à-vis des Français qui pourraient
donc passer par cette opérateur là qui
serait une espèce de diagnostic globale
sur la pathologie de leur logement et
aussi sur voyez des diagnostics
peut-être que l'on pourrait avoir
régulièrement je ne sais pas avec elle
périodicité selon le type de patrimoine
auquel nous sommes confrontés voilà mes
questions je vous remercie alors
quelques éléments de réponse donc pour
les ménages modestes justement est un
vecteur qui permet d'obtenir des
rénovations énergétiques globales
performantes puisque le ménage n'a pas
besoin de s'endetter n'a pas besoin de
faire un prêt c'est l'opérateur ensemble
et qui porte l'investissement donc de ce
point de vue là ça résout le problème
justement des de la difficulté des prêts
pour les ménages modestes
et bon la difficulté des pré aussi pour
les autres ménages qui eux sont
pourraient les obtenir mais souvent ne
souhaite pas s'endetter donc et par
ailleurs pour que bien évidemment la
rénovation énergétique ne se limite pas
à faire des gestes qui génèrent les
économies d'énergie mais qui améliorent
bien aussi le confort qui fasse donc ce
qu'on appelle une rénovation énergétique
globale performante donc à la taille
catégorie AOB quand c'est pas une
passoire thermique et au moins catégorie
C quand c'est une passoire thermique là
c'est du point de vue de la
réglementation justement la puissance
publique pourrait définir que
l'opérateur ensemblier doit atteindre
que doit faire
la rénovation
énergétique globale performante pour
atteindre ses seuils et sinon il ne peut
pas faire donc ce contrat avec les
particuliers donc de ce point de vue là
c'est
déjà on a déjà eu l'occasion d'échanger
avec des entreprises sur intéressées par
ça et c'est vraiment faisable on a
également évalué aussi ce qui est
faisable en termes de financement par
les rénovation énergétique ça permet
d'atteindre ces seuils là donc ça
permettrait
de vraiment améliorer le confort et pas
juste la baisse de consommation
d'énergie et par ailleurs alors ça c'est
une suggestion c'est pas quelque chose
que nous avons encore étudié en détail
mais la puissance publique pourrait
mettre aussi des conditions pour
améliorer enfin déjà pour demander donc
à l'opérateur un sanglier d'évaluer la
qualité du bâtiment donc indépendamment
de la rénovation énergétique le fait que
est-ce que il y a un risque qu'il
s'effondre ou quoi que ce soit ça il
pourrait ça pourrait être quelque chose
qui l'intégrer puisqu'il fait de toute
façon quand même un diagnostic thermique
et donc il va quand même étudier le
bâtiment de près et par ailleurs aussi
en réalisant les travaux donc là il
pourrait y avoir cette obligation
supplémentaire bien évidemment ça
rajoute un coup pour la rénovation
énergétique donc il serait quand même
utile que la puissance publique si elle
met cette obligation mettre une partie
de ce enfin de ce coup supplémentaire
pour pas que ça vienne plomber encore un
peu plus des rénovations énergétiques
qu'elles mettent des aides
spécifiquement puisque là on sait quand
même qu'on a un gros intérêt collectif
de beaucoup mieux anticiper quand un
bâtiment un risque de s'effondrer enfin
ou quoi que ce soit et donc ça
l'opérateur semble biais pourrait en
avoir la responsabilité mais à condition
quand même qu'on mobilise des aides pour
pour cette partie là du de
l'investissement qui pour beaucoup sinon
ça va faire monter le prix des
rénovations énergétiques et qui pourront
moins se rembourser par les économies
d'énergie quoi une autre
[Musique]
donc par ailleurs y compris d'ailleurs
sur les initiative de mieux adapter les
logements au vieillissement comme je le
mentionnais tout à l'heure pour la
gestion de l'eau c'est des choses que on
peut aussi demander aux opérateurs
ensemblier de développer
alors bien évidemment sur l'adaptation
du logement pour qu'il soit mieux adapté
aux ménages plus âgés ça bien évidemment
ça ne sera pas nécessairement financé
par la rénovation par les économies
d'énergie mais là dessus on peut
mobiliser les aides publiques qui
existent déjà là-dessus et également
éventuellement trouver d'autres types de
financement pour pour que cette partie
là des travaux se fasse en complément
donc de la rénovation énergétique et
comme les si tout est fait ensemble
ensemble ça permettra de faire baisser
le coût unitaire justement à la fois de
la rénovation énergétique et à la fois
aussi de si on séparait juste de faire
des travaux pour mieux adapter le
logement
[Musique]
au vieillissement de ces résidents quoi
et où à la gestion de l'eau aussi quoi
par ailleurs alors sur la question
posée par Monsieur comptart sur la
question des matériaux bio sourcés c'est
absolument effectivement un des enjeux
majeurs pour pour le pays et plus pour
la planète bien entendu
et clairement alors dans un premier
temps pour les opérateurs enseignés
il ne vaut mieux pas leur mettre des
contraintes plus élevées que les que les
opérateurs classiques de la rénovation
énergétique parce que sinon on leur
barrerait la route en quelque sorte en
revanche une fois qu'il y aura que ça
aura démarré
il est possible de mettre des
réglementations là-dessus de mettre donc
des contraintes supplémentaires ça
aiderait à développer l'offre de manière
forte notamment l'offre pour les
matériaux parce que par exemple on sait
que pour le chanvre etc il faut arriver
à faire baisser les prix il faut arriver
en produire beaucoup plus
et aussi que les professionnels
sachent beaucoup mieux utiliser ce
matériel ce matériau plutôt que
d'autres matériaux classiques quoi donc
là dessus le rôle de la réglementation
des incitations
seraient notamment par exemple en mieux
en mobilisant les aides dans un premier
temps et une fois que la
donc que l'offre en fait à la fois chez
les professionnels et puis en termes de
matériaux auraient répondu à la demande
on peut mettre des contraintes
pour pour que ça soit ces matériaux là
qui soit qui deviennent obligatoire en
quelque sorte on a un enjeu
je suppose que vous l'avez vraiment bien
en tête c'est l'enjeu pour la montée en
puissance la rénovation énergétique
c'est que nous devons faire monter en
compétence et former beaucoup de
personnes
beaucoup de partisans ou autre qui
travaillent aujourd'hui dans la
construction qui
devrait s'orienter vers la rénovation
énergétique donc là il y a un enjeu
absolument essentiel bien évidemment du
point de vue de la puissance publique
des collectivités territoriales de mieux
aider à monter en qualité dans la dans
la formation et
de ce point de vue là justement aussi
l'opérateur en sanglier est un élément
qui peut être un vecteur porteur pour
mieux orienter et mieux former plus de
personnes dans la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments puisque c'est ces acteurs
vont réaliser comme un des
investissements importants vont
développer des relations avec des
artisans avec d'autres corps de métiers
dans et
clairement ils vont travailler avec eux
de manière beaucoup plus régulière donc
les aider à les former éventuellement
même investir dans la formation pour
qu'ils puissent répondre à leurs
demandes et donc ça va aider vraiment à
structurer l'écosystème et à faire
monter en compétence orienter plus de
compétences vers la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments
permettez-moi je reviens sur ma question
c'est à dire le profil de ces opérateurs
ensembly vous êtes en train de nous
décrire en fait un architecte un maître
d'oeuvre je ne comprends pas très bien
parce que en réalité il va avoir
beaucoup de tâches à faire c'est
opérateur ensemble et c'est à dire que
d'un côté il doit devoir se préoccuper
des compétences à trouver et donc à les
former éventuellement le cas échéant
vous avez parlé dans vos propres
introductifs que ils vont prendre en
charge de la conception jusqu'au suivi
et donc j'imagine jusqu'à la livraison
fin de chantier
je suis même au-delà puisque
effectivement il est à l'engagement sur
les performances donc j'ai envie de dire
pardon je ça fait pas un peu usine à gaz
ça fait pas un machin un peu un peu trop
gros et finalement qui va le contrôler
et on va se contenter de chiffres c'est
à dire il va nous dire ben là ils
étaient à temps maintenant ils sont à
temps pour donc c'est bon et vous êtes
enfin voilà est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un peu plus parce que j'ai
l'impression on est en train de
éventuellement de d'avoir quelque chose
de une espèce de machin un petit peu
gros qui va prendre en charge tout cela
et hop et on sera dans le meilleur des
mondes tout sera résolu grâce à ses
opérateurs enseigner excusez-moi je suis
juste un petit peu et aucun moment enfin
on sait qu'il y a des métiers
aujourd'hui qui font ça qui font de la
coordination donc je me posais bêtement
la question voilà tout à fait et c'est
justement l'usine à gaz plutôt que ça
soit une usine à gaz que les
particuliers doivent gérer ou les
copropriétés c'est justement une
entreprise qui le gère et elle sera
mieux le gérée parce que justement c'est
son métier sa compétence qui va se
développer de ce point de vue là de
savoir bien faire la conception du
projet pour la rénovation énergétique de
bien s'assurer de la qualité des travaux
de bien donc réaliser ces travaux et
comme elle se rembourse sur les
économies d'énergie
sont c'est justement son intérêt est
vraiment aligné avec le fait que la
rénovation énergétique sera performante
et donc bien évidemment il y aura un une
transmission d'information
à l'agence de régulation pour faire un
suivi mais le risque de de malfaçon ou
quoi que ce soit et beaucoup plus faible
que dans le cas classique puisque là si
l'entreprise qui donc l'opérateur en
semble y est qui est le maître d'oeuvre
et qui en même temps assistant à mettre
d'ouvrage c'est un contrat de conception
réalisation
si
le maîtrise mal donc à la fois le choix
des différents artisans encore de
métiers qui vont faire les différentes
opérations le fait le mal le suivi etc
bien évidemment c'est lui qui c'est
comme les économies d'énergie sont pas à
la clé c'est lui qui porte des pertes
donc clairement c'est justement ces
entreprises vont développer ses
compétences il en existe déjà quand même
des entreprises qui ont ces compétences
qui font déjà de l'accompagnement de
qualité dans les rénovations
énergétiques et elles sont très diverses
il y a des entreprises qui sont plutôt
des PME il y a des entreprises qui sont
plutôt des grandes entreprises il y a
des fédérations d'artisans qui sont
aussi dans ce dans ce genre de d'action
c'est également le cas aussi des
sociétés d'économie mixtes que sont les
sociétés de tiers financement donc en
fait il y a une grande diversité sur les
acteurs potentiels qui peuvent rentrer
dans ce dispositif et là-dessus il y a
ce qui est la garantie c'est que
justement
comme leur rentabilité et directement
impactée si jamais il ne maîtrise pas
bien les travaux si jamais il ne les
économies d'énergie sont pas à la clé ou
quoi que ce soit
on est bien sûr pour la pour la
collectivité pour la puissance publique
que le risque sera beaucoup de de
malfaçon de
du coup de rénovation énergétique non
performantes etc sera beaucoup plus
faible et par ailleurs et il sera facile
pour la puissance publique de faire un
suivi parce qu'en fait il pourra y avoir
une transmission d'information
automatique excenté c'est à dire avant
la rénovation énergétique le dans la
proposition du contrat que le que
l'opérateur ensemblait fait un
particulier ou à une copropriété il
transmet en fait à l'agence qui sera
chargé de sa régulation
quel est le coût des travaux qu'il
anticipe quel est les économies
d'énergie qu'il anticipent
donc déjà excenté
l'agence de régulation pour avoir s'il
est coûts des travaux qu'ils donnent
sont
trop faibles par rapport à ce que ils
vont être bien trop élevés elle voit si
en opérateur en sanglier se trompe trop
souvent puisqu'en fait après le la
réalisation des travaux donc les un an
ou deux ans après il y a transmission
des coûts effectifs des travaux et il y
a transmission des économies d'énergie
effectivement donc il est facile de voir
sur chacune des opérations si
l'opérateur ensemblait se trompe sachant
que même s'il se trompe c'est lui qui
porte les pertes donc c'est pas négatif
pour les pour les particuliers
et c'est pas assez un risque beaucoup
moins important que quand on leur
demande de payer des travaux qui sont
très coûteux et que ces travaux ne
génèrent pas en fait une rénovation
énergétique performante là il ne paye
pas
puisque c'est juste les économies
d'énergie qui gèrent qui qui financent
ces travaux donc et par ailleurs donc
comme
l'agence de régulation à les
informations de manière automatique sur
quel est le coût effectif post
rénovation quelle est la consommation
effectivement
elle peut voir si un opérateur ensemble
lié a tendance à se tromper trop souvent
ou si son coup par exemple pour la
rénovation d'un bâtiment et plus élevé
que notre pour la rénovation équivalente
quoi d'un bâtiment équivalent
sachant que les risques
les risques sont quand même beaucoup
plus faibles que dans le cas classique
puisque là elle est vraiment les
intéressants alignés puisque le
l'opérateur se rembourse donc sur la sur
vraiment ça maîtrise de la rénovation
performante et sur les économies
d'énergie que ça que ça réalise mais
c'est quand même important de le suivre
si jamais il y en a un qui faisait trop
d'erreurs quoi
voilà
merci alors il me reste deux questions
je sais pas si je me suis rapporté à
votre a conclure Amel gaker et
Jean-Jacques Michou merci dans la
continuité en fait de l'intervention de
ma collègue toujours sur cette opérateur
en sanglier
vous faites fille sur le théoriquement
ça paraît très intéressant c'est
intéressant parce que vous répondez à
une grande partie des difficultés
rencontrées notamment cette complexité
que peuvent rencontrer aujourd'hui les
ménages dans leur projet par contre vous
faites chi de du contexte de pénurie de
matériaux par exemple de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dont certains secteurs de la
rénovation et thermique et je voulais
savoir si vous aviez justement en tête
ces difficultés là des réponses des
propositions en tout cas sur sur cette
difficulté et puis la deuxième chose
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure le fait
que ce modèle entre guillemets
n'existait pas réellement en tout cas
exactement sous cette forme là mais
une forme en tout cas pouvait ressembler
ailleurs est-ce que vous pourriez nous
en dire plus merci oui alors donc pour
les formes qui existent ailleurs et qui
sont proches donc les sociétés de
service financement sont très proches
certains délégataires C2E qui font de la
compagnement de déjà aujourd'hui de
l'accompagnement dans les rénovations
énergétiques sont proches mais pour
l'instant c'est pas eux qui portent
l'investissement et donc là ça garantira
d'une part un meilleur aliment des
intérêts d'autres parts aussi le la
réponse à l'enjeu principal qui est
comment mobiliser des financements
parce qu'on sait que les particuliers
bien entendu on est des difficultés de
ce point de vue là donc ça c'est on est
on est dans on est dans des situations
enfin le l'opérateur en sanglier ça
n'est pas
un pas très important par rapport aux
situations actuelles c'est un pas de
plus qui est de porter l'investissement
et ça permet d'aligner les intérêts et
de gagner donc en efficacité et en
qualité et c'est d'ailleurs un des
éléments très important c'est que ça
permettra de regagner la confiance parce
que clairement quand il y a quelques
maisons ou quelques copropriétés qui
auront été rénovés de cette manière là à
sans que les particuliers ne payent rien
de plus que s'il n'avait pas fait la
rénovation énergétique que la rénovation
est performante il y aura quand même
rapidement du bouche-à-oreille sur le
fait de pouvoir utiliser ce type de
dispositif et d'avoir confiance sur le
sur les résultats parce qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement les bouche à oreille
fonctionne plutôt dans l'autre sens quoi
les gens ont plutôt peur de ne pas avoir
une rénovation de qualité et par
ailleurs donc
[Musique]
sur bien entendu l'enjeu de
la disponibilité de la main d'oeuvre et
des entreprises est un enjeu absolument
essentiel d'ailleurs France stratégie et
mobilisé sur une mission qui nous a été
confiée par l'Assemblée nationale pour
identifier la concrètement le besoin
justement en main d'oeuvre et en
compétences pour donc la rénovation
énergétique
compte tenu de la trajectoire de
l'ambition que nous avons pour
être sur l'objectif de zéro émission
nette en 2050 donc là les travaux sont
en cours mais bien évidemment c'est un
sujet que nous avions déjà bien en tête
et
justement en aidant à mieux structurer
l'écosystème par notamment des marques
qui vont être plus qui vont avoir plus
de confiance de la part des
particuliers
clairement ça sera quelque chose qui va
plus être attractif pour des personnes
qui voudraient se lancer dans ce métier
pour attirer des jeunes pour s'y former
et de ce point de vue là on a quand même
quand on a quand même les les
[Musique]
donc de s'assurer quand que bien
évidemment le l'artisan qui se
reconvertit vers la rénovation
énergétique alors qu'il n'y était pas
que dans un premier temps il y a un
suivi par l'opérateur ensemble billet et
qui le qui s'assure de sa formation quoi
et justement ça ça permettra de monter
en puissance de ce point de vue là quoi
alors probablement qu'il faudra aussi
quand même des aides publiques pour
développer plus de d'organismes de
formation dans ce domaine
et peut-être aussi pour que les une part
plus grande de nos de nos jeunes
travailleurs
ail dans ce dans ce domaine là avec des
incitations mais clairement le facteur
essentiel c'est quand même de mieux
structurer l'écosystème parce que sinon
si on n'a pas les acteurs qui font
l'investissement et puis qui assurent
vraiment le recrutement de manière de
performante avec la qualité du travail
la qualité de l'environnement de travail
etc et la performance justement de la
rénovation parce que ça aussi c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est très
important puisque les on sait bien que
les salariés finissent par où les
artisans qui se remobilisés finiraient
par ce
enfin se démobiliser si jamais les
rénovations n'étaient pas performantes
quoi et que ils avaient et que les
particuliers comme ce qu'on a beaucoup
constaté dans le passé avait
l'impression de d'être plutôt victime
d'arnaque parce que
en termes de d'économie d'énergie c'est
un générez pas tellement des communes
énergies
Jean-Jacques Michaud
oui merci pour tous ces renseignements
et dans la continuité du questionnement
je voudrais que vous m'éclairiez si j'ai
bien compris les les locataires ou
propriétaires de ces immeubles
remboursera la différence entre ce qu'il
payait en termes d'énergie avant les
travaux et après les travaux
ceci étant quand on sait qu'un locataire
reste deux ou trois ans dans un bâtiment
et qu'un propriétaire reste propriétaire
à 8-10 ans est-ce que les relations
entre
la personne qui qui remboursera une
partie le delta ce se fera c'est parce
que c'est plutôt lié au bâtiment que
personne donc ce sera une servitude
notariée comment vous avez
réfléchi à cette relation là il y a
différentes choses c'est à dire que
alors si on est sur une copropriété donc
avec des bailleurs et
[Musique]
et par ailleurs
les la clause c'est que le propriétaire
si le vend son appartement il a le il a
deux options la première option c'est
d'intégrer le restant du à l'opérateur
ensemble lié dans son prix de vente donc
et il fait de ce point de vue là
soit il intègre dans son contrat de
vente le fait que le nouvel acheteur
doit
reprendre le contrat avec l'opérateur en
sanglier donc du coup le nouvel acheteur
paye moins cher que si dans le prix de
vente il y avait il y avait
l'intégration du prix de la rénovation
énergétique et il continue à payer une
facture énergétique et qui Valante à
celle qui aurait eu lieu s'il n'y avait
pas eu la rénovation énergétique tant
que l'investissement n'est pas
finalisé quoi remboursé
donc de ce point là c'est simple à
transmettre
ça ne oblige pas de d'attacher le
contrat au logement au bâtiment c'est
juste une clause dans le contrat que le
propriétaire doit aller soit le soit
payer le restant du Silvant le logement
soit
intégré dans son contrat de vente le
fait de reprendre le contrat aux
nouveaux propriétaires et
idem pour le nouveau propriétaire
juste une question complémentaire sur le
sur ce système là que vous avez très
bien et très bien expliqué voir là si
vous avez déjà eu des retours la
perception des différents ministères que
ce soit Bercy ministère du Logement
transition écologique savoir si voilà
quelqu'un a intérêt en tout cas il porte
il porte à ce système et puis peut-être
aussi avec les organisations
professionnelles du bâtiment aussi
est-ce que vous avez déjà des échanges
et de retour par rapport à ça oui tout à
fait nous avons échangé avec beaucoup de
parties prenantes donc oui il y a un
fort intérêt des des différents
ministères pour ce principe
d'ailleurs normalement une un appel à
projet pour l'expérimentation doit être
lancée prochainement dans le cadre de
France 2030 au printemps
donc là nous sommes justement en échange
avec les différentes administrations qui
établissent les cahiers des charges et
donc
cet appel à projet d'expérimentation
doit être lancée prochainement dans dans
quelques semaines
et par ailleurs donc les
j'ai on a eu l'occasion d'échanger avec
effectivement les fédérations les
beaucoup de
d'acteurs du
secteur du bâtiment et beaucoup d'entre
eux sont intéressés par éventuellement
se lancer dans le concept d'opérateurs
incendié parce qu'il voit bien justement
l'intérêt en termes de faire monter très
concrètement l'ampleur du marché parce
que ils ont bien en tête
on sait que par exemple certaines
entreprises comme l'entreprise Bouygues
par exemple a dit on veut passer on est
à 80% de construction neuve 20% de
rénovation énergétique et on veut passer
enfin en 90 et on veut passer de à 80 20
au sens 80 de rénovation 22 construction
des choses comme ça enfin beaucoup de
gens dans le secteur beaucoup
d'entreprises et d'artisans dans le
secteur du bâtiment savent que bien
évidemment la part le la part du marché
qui va être la plus dynamique ça va être
maintenant la rénovation énergétique
parce que ça va devenir obligatoire et
puis surtout c'est un enjeu absolument
essentiel pour notre planète et par
ailleurs aussi justement en développant
ce concept qui n'est pas pour l'instant
développé dans d'autres pays la France
aurait la possibilité de développer
justement des entreprises qui pourraient
ensuite intervenir dans les pays tiers
parce qu'on sait que dans beaucoup
d'autres pays il y a aussi un sujet de
comment on finance ces rénovations
énergétiques quoi dans les pays qui ont
moins de revenus quoi et mais qui ont
quand même les factures énergétiques et
levées
merci beaucoup c'était très intéressant
merci Madame merci Monsieur et bonne
soirée à vous merci beaucoup et est-ce
que le document que vous avez présenté
on pourra il a été remis on pourra être
d'accord d'ailleurs il y avait aussi une
présentation sur l'opérateur incendié
alors je vous ai pas montré là les
jeunes
avec grand plaisir et nous sommes à
votre disposition si vous voulez en
reparler en détail sur certains points
merci beaucoup et bravo pour vos travaux
merci un point aussi enfin juste
peut-être
le fait de simplifier
la capacité de décision des copropriétés
et quelque chose d'absolument essentiel
de ce point de vue là pas juste pour
l'opérateur en sanglier d'ailleurs mais
pour les rénovations énergétiques et les
opérations permettraient justement de
répondre à ça parce que ça permettrait
une offre globale et donc il y aurait
juste un premier vote de la copropriété
de dire on a un intérêt à se faire
rénovation énergétique globale
performante sans payer rien de plus que
notre facture énergétique et ensuite les
opérations sangliers feraient
différentes offres pour ce bâtiment et
il y aurait un vote global de la
propriété pour choisir l'opérateur en
sanglier et ça serait le dernier vote
alors que aujourd'hui ils sont amenés à
faire des votes sur un peu toutes les
opérations chaque fois et donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui est un gros frein
parce que ça prend énormément de temps
pour réaliser la rénovation énergétique
je vais vous montrer